[MUSIC]
Can we talk about how you evaluate whether
someone will engage academically at
Stanford?
>> We're looking for students who are
curious, who are willing to share their
perspectives both inside and
outside of the classroom.
And perhaps most importantly,
we're looking for
students who want to seek new ideas,
new perspectives,
almost insights or truth, and
to do that in a collaborative way.
When you leave JSB as a leader,
you're going to go out and
have some tough problems to solve.
But you're not going to do it by yourself,
you're not going to do it
in your own head somewhere.
So really having someone who's going to be
leveraging the thoughts of others to come
up with the best possible
solution is important.
To assess these behaviors, we look at
multiple places on the application.
The most obvious would be the transcript.
And for me, I usually read,
I'll take a day, Tuesdays and
Thursdays during application season,
I get to read from home.
It's my favorite thing to do,
and every time-
>> It sounds fun.
>> [LAUGH] It is, I get really along
with the applicants and their stories.
But when I open a file, one of the first
things I do is I go to the transcript,
because that tells so much about someone,
what are the kind of courses you took?
What were you most interested in studying?
Are you someone who went broad and
liked to see how different
disciplines connect with each other,
or maybe someone who went very deep?
So, that's step one, and I do get
information about how curious someone is,
and how the rigor and
course choices impacted them.
But perhaps more importantly than
the transcript is looking for
evidence of this curiosity and
other things that people have done.
So perhaps you were at work and
there's a tough problems to solve, and
you worked with others to figure it out.
Or perhaps you did research at your
university beyond your classes.
One of my most recent favorite stories was
from someone we had met in this class,
it was an individual.
I think he was in business
development in a tech company,
it was a growing tech company.
And he joined when the company
was only about 50 people.
And he said one of the things he loved
the best when he joined was that,
wherever he was there was
laughter in the hallways.
And he thought that was a sign of
people being optimistic, innovative.
And then as time went on,
and they were doubling, and
tripling in size, the laughter went away.
>> Mm.
>> Yeah, and he remembered going
to an all-hands meeting, and
asked the senior management,
this is a concern, what can I do?
And came up with the idea
to do a pulse survey.
The only problem to check
in with the culture,
the only problem was he said he had
no idea how to do an HR survey.
What cultural engagement was?
How to build it?
How to write questions, all of that.
But you watch them go through a path of
just curiosity of meeting with experts,
both in the company and
outside of the company.
Researching material to figure out, yeah,
what are some good benchmark surveys?
How do we develop
questions that will work?
Luckily, they had some PhD students in
this company who were doing business
analytics that I could get help from.
But the point is, that's a great
story about using your curiosity, and
your drive to find truth
about this company.
They essentially came up with a great
answer about what they could be doing
differently as they move forward.
So, hopefully that helps give you
a sense of what I'm looking for and
how I'm looking for.